there's got to be a way and I know
you've done videos about this but I'll
just say there's got to be a way to both
love your ancestors and also be honest
about their sins yeah there's got to be
a way to do that and and right now it
seems like we can only do one or the
other that's actually a function of
idolatry it's an image of idolatry
because one of the things that happens
is that because we don't have the
fractal relationship because we don't
have this hierarchy that leads all the
way up to God we actually expect of
these lower rungs to be perfect and if
they're not perfect we hate them because
they're not perfect and so there's a
sense in which if things were properly
laid out and we don't treat these
figures as Idols to worship them or to
cast them down either way that we we see
them as just manifestations that are
great because they're not God you know
all these leaders all these Heroes have
dark sides obviously there's no way
around right yeah then we could
celebrate their heroism and also
recognize their sins
good
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
foreign
[Music]
I am very excited as usual to be here
with Richard Roland for the continuation
of our Universal history series this
time we're actually going to look at the
idea of national epics and the way in
which different nations would tell their
own story how in some ways they they
tried to pop out and to have their own
their own particular Vision but then
also how that ultimately still fits into
the idea of universal history so I'm
excited to go along with this so Richard
it's good for you to be here thank you
um before we get started I will say more
about this at the end because it is
cleverly related to our topic today
um uh but uh uh uh graceful Segways
abound in this in today's episode but uh
we have a I have a Kickstarter going uh
it should basically already be live when
this video drops or within a day or two
so they'll be linked down below
um it's to a tabletop role-playing game
called amborea role-playing in the world
understood light if you want to know
what the world under Starlight is and
why we're doing it as a role-playing
game and not some other medium I'm going
to answer those questions at the end of
the video it's funny when Jonathan when
you posted my uh it was here at the
kickstarter like the landing page you
know like a couple of people in the
comments like on YouTube or whatever
were like you know Christian shouldn't
be you know role-playing gameplay
I know yeah right well so anyway I'm
gonna talk about uh I'm gonna talk about
um uh actually very soon I'll be doing a
video with Father dick and Nicholas
kotar where we'll be talking about that
question specifically
um but uh but also so I'll say more
about that project at the end because
it's kind of related to the topic of
today's video
um but yeah so
part of the reason I wanted to talk
about this is because I have recently
met a bunch of like symbolic World folks
in the wild sometimes unexpectedly you
know uh usually they just show up at my
church shout out to Samuel if you're
listening Samuel uh who came to Vespers
on Wednesday night and he's like wait
what are you doing here well this is my
church what are you doing here but you
know but uh no it was it was great um
but uh so I've been talking to some
people who uh are kind of new to the
symbolic world in the Universal history
train
and so I thought it would be useful
because we've been doing these videos
for almost two years now I think crazy
yeah maybe actually two years I'm not
even sure anymore amazing uh we've been
we've done been doing them for a while
so I thought it might be useful to
revisit
a little bit and maybe kind of putting
some new terminology what we mean by
Universal history because one of the
things that I've noticed in my
conversations with people online and in
person
is that sometimes people sort of get a
little confused about what we mean by
medieval Universal history and we'll
mistake it for things that look similar
but maybe have completely different
goals so that's we're gonna start go for
it so
the symbolic medieval Universal history
is uh let's say sorry I'm looking down
at my notes It's a combination of the of
what let's call the Christian Mythic
content and by Mythic obviously I think
everybody should know by now I do not
mean faults right but Christian Mythic
content in the in the sense that it's a
myth that we live into a sacred story
Etc so there's a Christian Mythic
content which is obviously the Bible is
also the Apocrypha by which I mean the
actual Apocrypha not the director's cut
of the Bible
um and then it's and then it's also it's
also like the lives of the Saints and
then all the squiggly folklore
Traditions weird stuff you know
dog-headed Saints and the head of Saint
John the Baptist flying around haunting
people we were just talking about before
the recording started like stuff like
that like all that stuff that's kind of
out there more on the margins of the
tradition that's all kind of part of
this Christian Mythic content yeah so
it's that
Plus
the mythical content of Greece and Rome
and specifically the great classical
epics the homeric epics and the Aeneid
like if you want to really drill down to
to the core of that yeah and there's a
little bit of foray into uh more local
Mythic Traditions I'd say like
Scandinavian Traditions but but the
Greek and Roman mythological always ends
up being connected in some way even to
those Scandinavian Traditions yeah so
I'll get to the the more local stuff
here in just a sec because that's the
next part of this right so but this is
the this stuff together right becomes
the
um I I was I've been thinking about it
like in terms of hierarchy but it's
almost like when you when you hear me
say a hierarchy in this instance it is
better to understand it as like a series
of like nesting dolls rather than like
something that's really top heavy and
like an upside down pyramid or something
like that right yeah it's a fractal like
it's the best example of a fractal it's
like little identities exist in larger
identities and connect you know vertical
the biblical narrative you could say
right and so this container of the
Christian mythical content plus
Greco-Roman civilizations mythical
content the container of those two two
things together becomes a container
which is like large enough and sort of
robust enough to then contain this
multi-tiered hierarchical identity
within it so this is this is uh so
identity in the ancient world unlike the
way most of us think about identity
today we'll talk more about that later
is
um it's hierarchical that is it's
conveyed from the top down or from the
outside in right if you're thinking
about nesting dolls um
and it begins with God and it ends with
me so uh you have the you have God right
and then you have the sort of like the
the almost parallel streams and I
realize
there's a whole very long-running
historical debate about who has priority
the pope or the Emperor or whatever uh
or if you're in these you've got the
patriarch and the emperor but in any
case you know you've got God and then
you've got the uh the pope or the
patriarch and the emperor and then down
from there you have these various
increasingly localized principalities so
if we're talking about the church then
you've got under the patriarch you've
got like there's the holy you know the
base is your local bishop and then your
local Bishop there's the priest that
he's basically deputized to act on his
behalf like all the way down to you and
then if you're talking about that on a
national level I mean
it's not for nothing that the original
like Diocesan structure
of the like a diocese is a is a Roman
Imperial like uh uh division of
geography and and people like so like
the original like Metropolitan Diocesan
structure of the church in the early
centuries was basically they just used
what the Roman Empire kind of already
had in place right so that you would
have you would have these these
increasingly local nested identities
that are basically parallel
um
yeah it's important because you know
when a lot of modern historians when
they notice the gestures for example
that some local what they would call a
warlord makes towards the Emperor who is
like so far away and they have nothing
to do with they tend to dismiss that as
just irrelevant and or just and just uh
you know just words but but it if you
understand the way that people uh saw
identity then you can see that no this
gesture is very relevant to how they
anchor everything together and make
every and make everything make sense in
their world yes so in the way that that
worked for like worldly power structures
or ecclesiastical power structures it
also works for stories
so at the at the top or the outside you
have this
um uh uh oh and the other thing to say
about that that you know social
ecclesiastical hierarchy is that there
are holy people
uh a good example would be like your
local patron saint
right uh holy people sort of exist
outside or kind of bridge the hierarchy
in unexpected ways so if you live in a
small medieval village in Central Europe
or something like this you know you've
got the emperor and the patriarch and
everything way up here way up above you
but then like there's also your local
patron saint maybe it's Saint Nicholas
right so like if things are if things
are really getting out of hand
so you you have a uh you have a a path
of like appeal let's say right you can
you can go to Saint Nicholas and he can
go around I mean you know he can go
around the the pope or the patriarch or
the or the Emperor or whatever and to
kind of like help you out in your
situation so you've got holy people and
of course the prob the problem with
um the problem with modern people trying
to understand this is we all want to be
the person who's outside the hierarchy
right and it doesn't you know but it's
but it's really just the holy people and
when I say holy really hear that not
just in a sense of this is a good person
or a nice person but that in the sense
that this person is Sanctified or set
apart because there are there's also
such a sort of a thing as let's say uh
like uh the secular holy person which
I'll come back to in a minute right um
so anyway a secular in this holy person
in the sense that somebody's like a
secular but they're but they're set
apart
and because they're set apart they're
also sort of operating outside the
normal hierarchy of things yeah so it's
in some ways there there are ways in
which the hierarchies these are when I
said like in terms of a system it's it's
like fail-sized in the hierarchy yes yes
yes that's the way to I mean it's not
it's not as simple as that but it's a
good way for people to understand why
the hierarchies are never even even when
we talk about hockey they're never just
this simple top-down thing they have a a
kind of variability and and ways to to
shortcut when things go wrong along the
along the hierarchy itself actually so
um before we started talking about
before we started the recording we're
talking about the Arthurian stories a
little bit and uh the like but the night
errant
is a good example of that kind of a
person in in that sort of story right
because they they have this role that
puts them outside the normal hierarchy
so they show up in like a Barron's
district and the baron is evil and he's
awful and he's oppressing people and
it's like well where's the king why
doesn't the king know about what's going
on but but actually the night Aaron he
has like a he has a pipeline to the King
right so he's here from the round table
he's here from the king's court and he
sets things right and then he goes back
right he goes back to the court when
it's over so anyway that's that's an
example of that kind of thing um so if
this is true for like you could say
social ecclesiastical hierarchies it's
also true for the hierarchy of stories
when we're talking about Universal
history so we start with this kind of
one grand foundational story which is
sort of Mythic the the the the Mythic
content of Christianity plus Rome right
that's the ground foundational story
into which you have these increasingly
localized identity conferring patterns
the story of well now here's what here's
the story of my people when we converted
and then beyond that you might have
here's the story of my city or my
Village and beyond that you have uh you
have like here's my family history all
the way down to this is how my parents
raised me and all of that stuff and of
course what I'm really describing is the
idea of tradition yeah right all of that
stuff confers identity at all these
different levels but it has the
capability to kind of each of those
levels to be nested and obviously
obviously there are
certainly places that converted I mean
this is why we actually kind of started
the series with Ethiopia right is
because there are places that converted
that were outside the Roman Empire so in
that case they're they're actually like
the best proof case for like how this
works because it's not like they had any
like political you know yeah they had no
political reason to play this game yeah
no right there are meetings for the in
the same way another great example they
had no exact no reason because people
always say that it's just Constantine
and Rome and like we have several case
examples where that seems to not be the
case right right right right so so yeah
so um
any of these identity conferring stories
can be Aggregates or a pastiche
um and actually this is better
and this is another thing that to kind
of point out this is why
for purposes of what we're doing here
I'm deeply under interested in questions
like authorship yeah doesn't actually
matter right and the reason it doesn't
matter is because
uh certain kinds of things not
everything but certain kinds of things
actually have more Authority when either
we don't know who wrote them or or made
them or when the person who wrote or
made them is it has become a Mythic
person in some way right so to give some
some examples of this
um actually a really good example of
this is The Divine Liturgy and the the
Divine services in the Orthodox Church
yeah right there was no committee
that at any point in time sat down and
said here's the way we're going to do
things and there is not there's not a
regulatory body
across all the Orthodox churches in the
world that says all right everybody
we're making this change to liturgy this
year right it's not how it works
you can dig down into the history and
I've done this and there are lots of
people out there who've done this you
can dig down in history and figure out
oh this part appeared here yeah or this
prayer we this prayer maybe came from
Saint John of Damascus or you know like
the the but even then that's a saint
that's a holy person that is somebody
who's become a Mythic person right uh
but it's actually because it wasn't just
created by committee that it has the
kind of the weight and the authority and
the sense that you can't just do
whatever you want with it yeah right it
comes down from heaven right yeah it
comes down from heaven right that's the
that's but when we say something like
that that's what we mean we don't mean
that like the typical one dropped out of
the sky it's landed on someone's head
somebody else somebody's people you know
[Laughter]
um
what a silly what a silly image yeah uh
but yeah we don't mean that but what we
mean is that this is this is really it
passed down through the life of the
church right as opposed to it appears
like it appears and so because it's the
same with some of these icons not made
with hand you know people yeah yeah yeah
there's a way in which
the idea that the icon not made with
hands was never made by anybody I
understand I don't want to be I want to
be careful right it's like the idea that
these icons appear they kind of appear
out of nowhere they find them in the
water they they find them somewhere and
they they're kind of not they're just
they just happen uh and we don't know
who made them we don't know where they
come from uh but there's always there
always is like material causes if you
make spend a lot of time to try to dig
into them and that's not how we receive
them so that's why we we kind of see
them as this pattern kind of descending
from above and manifesting itself in the
world
that's a great example of this because
yeah there are some icons that that you
know we do believe when we say they're
not made with hands maybe you know what
we're really saying is you know there's
something miraculous about the creation
of this icon right the the the icon not
made with hands right the one that
Christ you know made of himself right
that's the that's like the ultimate
example right
um but but the uh but yeah when it comes
to some of these icons especially the
mother of God you know uh where this
icon appears in the field right
um the curse word icon I think is a good
example of this there's another icon I
can't remember the name of it now but I
I got to venerate it when I was in
Lithuania it was this tiny little sort
of Russian village church and really
large icon very beautiful and it just
sort of they found it in the field one
day yeah where did this come from how
did it get here right and so so it's a
Nikon not made with hands not because
not because anybody there is saying
nobody ever painted this or touched this
but it's just sort of it was just
received right it just came from heaven
in that sense right
um so yeah uh
typically speaking for these things like
they have to have some kind of a Mythic
Authority right this is why I mean Eve
all the way down at a fractal level this
is why sometimes when your parents tell
you something you won't listen
because you know your parents
right but then some other adult who you
do not know as well they tell you the
same thing and suddenly it's got cachet
yeah yeah right but I mean this is
actually why is the Jordan Peterson
clean your room it's like why is it
there right right everybody thinks it's
genius it's a perfect example perfect
example um but but I mean I mean for
instance this is why it's actually
you know better if you don't know what
Shenanigans the pope or whatever bishop
or like whatever patriarch so and so is
up to like it's better if you don't know
those things
actually because it you know because the
the Mythic let's say like the Mythic
distance that's actually part of the way
the hierarchy is supposed to work yeah
right and of course this inverts
ultimately at the moment of communion
when when everything gets you know
collapsed into the single point but uh
but it just is like a normal way of
operating through your life yeah it's
better if you don't know I want to say
something about this the hierarchy of
stories too that's important for people
to understand is that this again is is
one of the problems of our thinking is
that we tend to confuse quality and
quantity in the way that we see things
and so when a lot of modern historians
look at these these these original
histories they'll notice that there's
like I said there's a gesture at the
outset which says something like you
know we're connected to this son of Noah
or this related relation to the the the
Trojan War or whatever and then they'll
go into their National History and spend
a lot of time on it and so they'll tend
to dismiss the first part and say well
what's really important is this yes just
because it's one sentence or one page or
one paragraph doesn't mean that for the
people who wrote it it isn't
primordially important to be connected
in this way that it wasn't like the
reason why they even wrote their
National story is based in this first
little part that you dismissed and you
don't you don't think is important this
is such an important point that you're
making here because I've had
conversations with like Old Norse
Scholars and stuff
um you know about the what's sometimes
called the younger era or the prose Etta
which is uh we'll get to it eventually
but it's basically it was like uh this
is where like most most of the stories
from Norse mythology probably come from
this text but the text itself is a it
was a manual for poets written by a
Christian uh man uh name snori sterlison
right in the you know 14th century I
think 14th 15th somewhere in there
anyway long time after paganism had
already died out
uh and he's writing these stories down
because uh Norse poetry requires the use
of what are called Kennings which are
nested references and sometimes they go
several levels down and uh so if you
don't know the story that's being
referenced by the story that's being
referenced by the story then you won't
know how to use this in your scaldic
verse
um and so poetry as an art form was kind
of dying out and so snorri tries to
basically gather all the old stories and
I strongly suspect when he didn't
actually know the story he just made
something up that sounded good to him
but anyway
um nothing against him it's just like
some of that some of the stuff in there
is I think a little questionable if if
you wanted to really convince me that a
a seventh century Baltic Pagan actually
believed like this is what they thought
about Thor or something but anyway uh
but but the point point being uh point
being uh that that uh so he writes it
for that but then he begins it with this
very actually quite quite a long chapter
which connects it to the Christian story
and connects it to Rome where you find
out that all the Norse gods they're
actually refuges from the Trojan War and
they were actually famous men at one
point and Powerful Wizards and all this
other stuff right and um so I would but
when I when I've talked to Norse
Scholars like Scholars of Old Norse
literature about this you know I'll
mention something like well
the the prosetta you know it's got It's
uh it's got these features to it and
it's you know it's actually from a
Christian perspective because of this
stuff and and to look at me like you're
crazy I'm like well what about the
beginning though and then they'll say oh
well we don't count that that doesn't
count that's not you know like that's uh
he just had to do that so that the
church wouldn't you know as though as
though nobody in Christianity like had
ever you know told the story before like
you know and so it's just
I I have a hard time even articulating
how much this sort of thing irritates me
so yeah those those little bits there's
like the little Pro M at the beginning
of Sir Gowan and the Green Knight
um which connects which connects the
whole establishment of the kingdom of
Britain of which Arthur is now King uh
connects it to Brutus on the fall of
Troy yeah and all of the stuff like that
was actually deeply important to
understanding what the Arthurian story
was even about
um so much so that you know like that
particular Brutus gives his name to some
of the like early Arthurian poems uh the
lion man's Brut for example
um but without that
um
without that context like the story
wouldn't have been the same to them but
of course no the stories are actually
about you know
you know feminism and power struggles
and like all this other stuff and so
just that's way more convincing right
yeah yeah yeah right right right right
right
um um I'm actually probably just still
irritated about the sir going the Green
Knight film yeah came out a couple years
ago
um still pretty salty about that but
anyway okay so
the other thing to mention when we're
talking about these these kind of nested
hierarchies of stories in uh which is
really what I mean by medieval Universal
history right is
um is that folklore has the same kind of
function as like your local patron saint
as folklore is something that kind of is
able to
uh jump outside or like buttress the
hierarchy kind of from the outside and
so folklore will often just like bring
two things together that don't really
like you know these two people could not
have lived at the same time or the these
you know this um
uh you know well this obviously happened
here or not here or something like that
but folklore can collapse those
distinctions in a way that supports the
symbolic structure of the hierarchy yeah
um in the same way that your patron
saint can like collapse the distance
between you and the Emperor or or
whatever so yeah yeah well I mean you
see that even in hagiography right what
is it you know you can do it with Saints
because they can kind of come back from
heaven and do things you know what is it
yeah yeah
who is it I forget that is it saying
Demetrios who is the who's the Empire oh
oh yeah during his life right it's like
um you know God forgive me I can't
remember right now I know me too it's
horrible but they say Demetrios is shown
in an icon killing a king like killing
and uh and and it's not during his life
it's like you know after I'll think of I
think it was saying it as probably like
before the end of the video but yes
um
yeah so the Ground grand foundational
story of the Christian world is the
gospel you could say especially the
story that's from Genesis to acts and
then the apocalypse right uh but
especially the grand foundational story
of the Christian world is the passion
and the resurrection of Christ and this
is why in traditional Christianity
there's so much emphasis placed on Holy
Week or passion week and on Easter or
posca I mean if you want to
if you want to get like irrationally
irritated at English language
Christianity
um a great book to read is a book by an
English historian uh we've I've talked
about it before on the show but an
English historian named uh Eamon Duffy
um and he wrote this he wrote a bunch of
great books about prayer in the Middle
Ages but he has a fantastic book called
The stripping of the altars and one of
the there's a long chapter in this book
on basically how they celebrated posca
or the Easter Vigil in England before
the reformation and just like your
average Parish Church
and it's so
it's so Orthodox like it's so it's so
similar to the way that Orthodox
Christians are used to celebrating Pasco
or Easter today
um and and like and and you just sort of
realize oh no we had this at one point
and it was all stripped away from us
um it took me a while to get over that
yeah to be honest with you right
um but so then after this you have a
wide range of stories like we're talking
about with increasing locality that Nest
the local and the specific within the
universalizing and the cosmic so our
Universal history series we've been
mainly focused on these kinds of stories
this is what we've been mainly looking
at right how did people groups as they
converted Nest their identity within the
Christian and within the Roman story
even when they themselves maybe fell
outside of the empire
um
and uh just to to emphasize again before
we get into the next section is that
these identities they they stack or they
nest um and if you don't understand this
then you will make the mistake
which as as I'm going to try to argue is
basically the mistake of of 19th and
20th Century nationalism yeah which used
to create something that's very top
heavy
right
um where it's it's more about here's the
narrative that actually has to control
and oppress everything beneath it rather
than serve as a container for it yeah
that's really that's really important
and that's when you can see I mean in
general that's when you can see how when
any identity goes wrong is when it
doesn't respect the normal nesting of
identities that are below it right it's
like as a a family a father it's like
okay the father is the head of the
family but the father is the head of the
family in the way that is there to make
his children and his wife be fruitful
and and and and and succeed and be
themselves right and have their own
lives ultimately and so that's the way
that all identities should function now
that's the way God functions and that's
the way that already all identity should
function that's why people are when we
talk about nationalism they become very
tense because they always think that all
that means is like you said you know the
way that the Third Reich presented their
nationalism yes this completely identity
that takes over but it's not just the
third right Greg Napoleon uh and all of
a lot of modern uh national identity had
that that feature but it was not a
feature of ancient thinking yeah
um I think a much overlooked Vision in
scripture is Nebuchadnezzar's like first
dream
right the one I think it's his first one
but the one of the tree right so he has
the everybody remembers like the vision
of like the statue being destroyed by
the the you know the stone cut out of
the cut out of the mountain you know and
but um the the but in his vision of the
tree right it's the idea of the tree of
course the tree is the king
right the tree is is this beautiful tree
it gives shade to the plants beneath it
and also the birds of the air come and
nest in its branches the wild beasts
kind of gather around it but that's what
that's what the king is supposed to be
and you could say that that's what
whatever your your story that gives
identity that's what it is supposed to
be right it's supposed to be this tree
that you know the birds of the air these
various principalities and the beasts of
the field which are you know the things
that are lowered down right they can
come and still they can find shelter and
shade and protection
and of course in in his dream ultimately
he's because of his pride the tree gets
cut down but the point the point is that
this is what this is what the king or
you could say like the the Grand Story
like whatever it is that's what it
that's how it's supposed to function
yeah yeah and um obviously this didn't
always like function
perfectly
but there is
um
uh but it but it it functions
surprisingly well let's just say right
even when you have even when you have uh
somebody like the pope saying I think
it's maybe the fifth century saying okay
nobody in the west is allowed to read
The Book of Enoch anymore you know but
then there were still places on the you
know the outer branches of of the West
you know in in Scotland and Ireland and
the British Isles particularly where
where people kept all of these things
right they sort of kept them they still
remembered them and it was still part of
again not just like a book and a
monastery but you know teaching from
Enoch teaching from the apocryphal books
was actually a major part of Parish life
in Anglo-Saxon England right and so
there's there's a there's a there was
space even when you when you had
somebody who tried to totalize things in
some way there was space for this stuff
to kind of fit in yeah and but one of
the reasons why that's why it's hard for
us to think that way is that because we
live in a technocratic society we we
confuse Authority with power because we
have the we have the capacity now for
authorities to have indefinite power and
so when when the president or whatever
when the the authorities say something
they can implement it completely into
all the way down whereas in an ancient
world that wasn't the case you know the
pope can be in Rome saying whatever he's
saying and he's going to have influence
but it's not it he doesn't have the
means to enforce it all through
Christendom and so there's always this
organic variability that that installs
itself just Naturally by just normal
human mechanisms
so yeah Along Comes the Protestant
Reformation
right and the result of the Reformation
it has to be remembered
that the Reformation took place in
Germany
right it's primarily at in his
Beginnings primarily a German religious
movement right obviously it gives France
and Switzerland and England other places
but originally it's primarily a German
religious movement except that
the Reformation didn't take place in
Germany because Germany did not exist
Germany is a made-up country
um fake news everybody
um no Germany's Germany's a made-up
country right there if you look at a
medieval map there's no Germany on that
map nope nobody who lived in the place
that we called Germany now would have
called themselves Germans actually they
still don't call themselves Germans but
um but uh a really fun game is actually
uh what's the name of German in other
languages and like every yeah what do
you call what do you guys call it in
French Alma yeah right right uh uh
because like the all of Maine region
right right so so it's yeah nobody who
lived there called themselves Germans
right this this German but Germany is a
modern construct yeah but the way that
it was built
the story sort of begins in the
Protestant Reformation I don't have like
a ton of time to go into this but let's
say that uh as a result for the
Protestant Reformation we got something
called the 30 Years War in Western
Europe which is one of the bloodiest
periods in Western Europe actually not
not the Middle Ages right but but this
is this is now in the modern period
um 30 years were incredibly bloody
struggle between Roman Catholics and
Protestants over basically a very small
slice of a very small slice of Western
Europe yeah and the result the end
result of the 30 years war is something
called the Treaty of Westphalia and one
of the things that comes about as a
result of that treaty is that they
decide okay your religion will be
determined simply by whatever
principality you live in so like if you
live in this little province
um
and some of these are quite small
basically the size of what in Texas
would be a county
um I don't know do you guys do you guys
call them parishes or counties or like
what's your what's the what's the unit
in Canada beyond the city
uh yeah we do have uh we do have
something like that I forget what
they're called yeah yeah yeah accounting
yeah yeah so um uh but basically these
very small principalities and your
religion if you live there would just be
whatever the official whatever the
religion of and so what happened was
that instead of instead of the instead
of the the identity conferred by the
Christian story being kind of the at the
very outside level
is that it collapsed down actually
several levels into the hierarchy and so
it goes from being here's a
universalizing story of passion week and
posca right of Rome and Greece of the
Trojan War and you know Saint John the
Baptist right all these things like this
is our universalizing story that kind of
is the container that holds everything
together and now that collapses actually
several rungs down the ladder right
um to now it's actually secondary to
your political identity now
once you kind of understand when that
happened and how that happened you can
then understand how it's actually a
pretty short trip to go from there to
now my religious Identity or my
spiritual Identity or whatever is
something that I confer upon myself
personal personal right yeah but but
also like but isn't that also like
political identity also has collapsed
down to that level now yeah so you're
you're you you can freely associate with
whatever political party you want at
least in some parts of the world
um but you know talking to the United
States you can freely associate with
whatever political party you want and
and everything about your identity has
collapsed down to the level of the self
of the self
so when all of this is going on though
and before it kind of gets all the way
down to that level
in the primarily in 18th and 19th
century Europe
you have the emerging of was sometimes
called the search for the national epic
yeah so why do we need the national epic
because we're not part of an Empire
anymore Holy Roman or otherwise we're
not part of an Empire anymore and we are
not part of and we're not even part of
the same religion anymore
right it's a bit I mean and listen
nowadays Protestants Roman Catholics
Orthodox like we can go out together and
we can have a beer and we can talk about
our differences and all these different
things nobody stabs anybody and that's
great I love that
don't get me wrong
but if you think for a moment that
somebody you know in uh the 30 Years War
believed that oh the Roman Catholic over
there and and me we're the same religion
basically and we're just quibbling over
a few small differences like
they this is not how people thought yeah
yeah they weren't killing each other
over small differences let's say so
anyway
um so you don't you're not held together
by the same religion anymore and you're
not held together by the same uh and and
you're not even held together by like
the the sort of like the Imperial story
right and so now what we need to do is
just try to find some other narrative
that can collect and hold our identity
together and this is the this is why
there's the search for the national epic
so something a lot of people don't know
um you're of course aware of Jacob and
Wilhelm Grimm the brothers Grim yeah
right and uh they're famous for a bunch
of fairy tales which they did not write
um they're the fairy tales that we know
is like the fairy tales of the brothers
Grim uh they were edited mainly by
Wilhelm but uh but they didn't write
those stories yeah what they did was
they went around collecting all the
oldest stories like the the children's
stories is what they would call them but
they went around just like correcting
all the old wives stories and all the
old children's stories and things like
this from these these tiny little
idiosyncratic you know valleys in
different places and what is now Germany
um and they're collecting they're
collecting these stories because the
oldest stories preserve the oldest words
and Jacob Grimm is a philologist he's
interested in really old words and so
his two great works that he composed
were
um the largest and most comprehensive
dictionary of the German language which
has ever been created and then also the
the uh
a an accompanying volume sometimes it's
called Teutonic mythology or
German mythology or something like that
it's got its own name in German
uh which I won't try to pronounce here
uh since we're on the internet but
um anyway you've got you've got
uh these two massive volumes one is this
is the German language and the other is
this is German mythology and yeah uh
they're both fascinating works his
tutank mythology is let's say has a lot
of problems from the perspective of
modern scholarship because once again
there were a bunch of gaps and he just
tried to fill the gaps in by guesswork
essentially
um and then but the fairy tales were you
know basically he was sending his grad
students out because grad students are
the uh the Mindless minions of the
academic world so he would send his grad
students out to basically collect these
stories and then later they edited them
together in a volume and that turned out
to be much more popular and and let's
say more enduring than the other two
works yeah but what a lot of people
don't know is that uh following the
German Revolution
um sometimes it's called the March March
Revolution uh when the uh when the
National Assembly of the National
Assembly uh of the German people is like
the first German Parliament uh was what
came together
Jakob Grimm had a seat
it wasn't just a seat in the parliament
but it was like a special chair not
really and he had a vote and everything
else and he got this enchanted with
politics it didn't really last but the
reason that they gave him this spot
in the like the very first German
Parliament ever
was because he was he was the great
German philologist he was the great
German you could say Storyteller in that
he was telling by collecting all these
old stories and trying to package them
and arrange them what he's actually
doing is
creating an identity
that is German yeah
an identity that's based in that's based
in the language that you speak
and who your ancestors were more than it
is in what your religion is or where you
live or those other things and so one of
the great you know questions of the time
was well you know as there as the German
state is being founded and there's
there's lots of like little revolutions
and different governing bodies and all
these different things it's difficult to
to track even if you have it all laid
out in front of you but basically one of
the big questions that they're trying to
answer is what does it actually mean to
be German
but it's not a religious question
anymore
right it's not a it's not it's not you
know you know so like what does it mean
to be German and
um
obviously eventually attempts to answer
that question are going to develop in
some really kind of unhealthy ways yeah
yeah and more nationalistic ways the way
we understand them now right right the
ancient world that like if there had
been some kind of German identity let's
say in France there was definitely more
of a let's say a basic French identity
even though all the regions still there
was still that issue where all the reads
and like your French identity was
basically that you know you're somehow
related to the king of France like
that's where your French identity comes
from you know you owe allegiance to the
king but then you probably don't speak
French you don't speak the same French
right in France does you speak some
other local dialect or whatever and and
you don't see that this allegiance to
the king of France as this totalizing
thing right as this thing that it's like
I am French and the way even that the
French would understand that today yeah
yeah I mean that's the thing about
nationalism as opposed to let's say the
older mode is is that your national
identity is now much more totalizing to
the point that it has the ability to
actually obliterate the things beneath
it
um I mean obviously well it's the French
is a good example when Napoleon took
over he basically you know imposed
Parisian French on the rest of France
right to make it one language he he he
he basically imposed a education system
on to all the different regions and
those that you know and you can see that
all like during the revolution you can
see that happening it's wild you know
the the the the local places that resist
the revolution you know they get they
get slaughtered and people just get
slaughtered because they they there's
this one thing nacion right that that's
where even the idea is is kind of born
right this idea of a citizen of a Nation
the way that we just did it now
yeah and it's a sort of uh a weird
extension you could say of like the the
old really old classical idea of the
city-state yeah but now impose across
many cities and over a very large
geographic area until you get to these
places where you have the situation
today where Modern Nation States are so
impossibly large I mean this is part of
why I keep demurring on like when we're
gonna do like what's the symbolism of
America
uh video right part of it is is that
like which America yeah like well don't
you think that one of the reasons for
the success of America has been that it
had had been at least for a while had
been able to kind of recast that
multiplicity right a sense in which
there were local Traditions local places
you know people people in different
regions just have different ways of
living and we kind of don't feel like
the like the the centralized Authority
has the right or the capacity to impose
ways of being ways of thinking on on the
people in the local areas
yes there yes there is a uh
uh I think that was part of a lot of the
early Genius of the American project and
the two the two things that really
challenged it and maybe broke it
um although we'll see we're still I mean
we're brand new country so we'll see but
uh one is one is the the creation of the
interstate highway system yeah you know
the ability you know which is
very importantly uh it's like it's like
now it's the artery right the the
arterial system that connects the
country but very importantly like it's
it's owned and paid for by
decentralized power the federal
government right but then also and also
along with that
um you know kind of developing as well
as the is the there's something in our
Constitution called the interstate
commerce clause which basically gives
the federal government authority to
regulate anything that might possibly
touch interstate commerce and I don't
want to get like too much into like
American constitutional stuff and
politics but you could just say that the
the the kind of the Brilliance of the
great localized Pro uh uh you know being
able to recast that locality like you
just said
that start that is that started to break
down when those two things and obviously
airplanes have made things worse but
yeah but anyway but it's interesting
because here in Canada we can really see
where that leads to is that it actually
leads to Extremes in some ways you know
here in Canada we're seeing the Other
Extreme where as we know as the federal
government becomes more powerful it's
creating this sense that you know
diversity only diversity like we don't
have an identity this is this has been
now the the uh the way that the the
government is framing it is that Canada
is a is a nation-less nation right it's
a post-national nation we don't our only
value is openness like our only identity
is diversity and so it's almost this
like weird collapse like this I like how
you guys took took the like the joke
about Canadians being hyper apologetic
for everything and just like what if we
turn that into
an identity like what if we turn that
into her when I did and so and it's
interesting because in Quebec we we have
a weird fractal thing about that which
is that in Quebec they're trying to hold
on to their identity but they really
think of it in terms of nation like
really in terms of the French project in
terms of nation uh and so it's all
collapsing because they're trying to
like impose language and impose identity
over over the over Quebec but they also
but they don't feel it it's not an
organic thing and so as they're
including they're like you know we have
this massive immigration policy
recruiting all these people but they
have to learn French and they have to
they have to kind of fit into this weird
thing it's like well it's not it's all
not working like there's something so
inorganic about about about that in in
let's say in the Roman Empire you would
have had let's say groups of Barbarians
that would come and maybe settle and
they would negotiate with the local
person and they would let them settle
they would kind of they would keep their
identity but they would also pay homage
to the Romans but it would be of way
more organic natural way but but it's
almost impossible to do now yeah
yeah so
we thought we would get into politics so
much I know I know well I mean I it's my
own fault for picking the subject right
yeah because it's like it's it is kind
of especially as you get closer and
closer to modern times it becomes more
and more inherently political so you
have as as
as the old idea of the Empire Holy Roman
or otherwise right as the old idea of
the empire recedes
as Christianity as a central unifying
story as that gets pushed more and more
to the back burner let's say
um you know as a result of the
Enlightenment projects and everything
else
something has to step into that space to
fill the void that says like well okay
how do I know I'm
finish right how do I like what does it
mean to be finished like Finland has
been part of the you know talking
talking about the 19th century now right
so finland's been part of the Russian
Empire for a long time right
um but but but like you know nobody in
Finland speaks you know like the same
language that Tsar speaks and everything
so like
what would a finish identity what would
that look like yeah right and so they're
trying to figure that we figure that out
and answer that question and because so
much of the Enlightenment project looked
back at a
um very how do I say literally a very
monochrome uh version of The Classical
period right I say literally monochrome
because
um
uh you know that you know they go over
to Greece or Rome or whatever and they'd
see here's all these beautiful old white
marble pillars and temples and things
like this and so they assume oh
everything must have been like this and
it's so clean and it's so orderly and
all this different stuff and then for
decades for many decades like when
whenever uh whenever uh uh uh evidence
would emerge that this statue or that
these pillars had been painted
like I mean we go we've gone to church
with Greeks like you can't tell me those
people they paint those statues come
paint those statues come on come on
right but um
but but whenever evidence like this
would surface they would destroy it yeah
because it destroyed this sort of
pristine monochrome hyper-ordered
Vision that they had kind of created out
of the Classical period and you realize
nothing like that but but that's that's
the vision that they kind of created for
themselves
um and I think it was so appealing
because it basically offered a a
structured ordered framework that was is
like oh look how pristine things were
before it was touched by Christianity
and Christianity is what brought in all
this awful color and texture and
actually diversity right
um uh into the classical project right
and so anyway so this is the way that
this is the way that that uh that they
they were thinking about it at this time
and so looking back at The Classical
period they said well they had the
Aeneid they had the Iliad and the
Odyssey so if we're going to create a
Finnish national identity then what we
need is a Finnish epic and so I'm just
using this as an example because it's
probably my favorite from this period as
there's a guy named Elias lonerot who
went around and basically collected all
the old Finnish songs
about the the the sort of like the
ancient Heroes and the creation of the
world and you know a lot of the stuff
only survived in folklore right so he
goes around and he collects the songs
from all these people who you know can't
read they can't write but they have
hours and hours and hours of poetry just
memorized off the top of their head and
he he collects all that stuff together
and then he synthesizes it into a single
epic work called the kalivala now there
was never any such thing
in like medieval Finland it's a made-up
epic it's made up of real Parts but it
was created it was synthesized
um it's by the way extremely dope very
beautiful it's been well like one of the
most I I think actually especially in my
young life but even now like one of the
most influential pieces of poetry that
I've ever read so I I do recommend it
it's awesome and it uh there were parts
of it that also had a huge influence on
a lot of tolkien's development because
because it was really I mean it was just
being translated in English when Tolkien
was a kid oh yeah that was like it was a
big deal
but you've got other examples of of the
search for the national epic Beowulf is
my favorite the only reason we know
about Beowulf
um the the only reason the manuscript
isn't muldering somewhere in a library
totally forgotten is because
when they found it a lot of people
started saying oh well maybe this is
maybe this is our national epic and so
they would say oh well maybe Beowulf
maybe it's uh started out the date with
the Danes oh it's the Danish national
epic because a bunch of the characters
in it are Danes there's a Danish King in
here right and then the Germans said no
no it's a German National epic because
it's written in Anglo-Saxon which is a
West Germanic language and so is German
so this is a German National epic and
not until like almost a century later
uh did uh uh the English come along and
say well actually it was written in in
English so uh but but there are no
English characters in the story right so
it's it doesn't really qualify there's
not anybody's complicated yeah it's just
not a national epic it like it doesn't
fit the bill but a lot of people wanted
it to be in so that's that's how it kind
of rose to prominence
um obviously you've got like uh you know
the probably the actual German National
epic right the the Niva London lead uh
that like uh which you know Wagner's
whole ring cycle is built off of that
um
the sagas of the icelanders which which
all together you know for the Icelandic
people that's their Shakespeare
um and um obviously you know the the Sid
uh for you know people on the Iberian
Peninsula and
I know at one point the song of Roland
Roland was supposed to be the French
national epic right but it's such a it's
such a it's such a strange uh story to
be a national happy because it's a sort
of defeat and yeah you know and it's
like well defeat is okay
um lost causes are actually some of the
best most successful National ethics but
but it's I don't know it just it doesn't
seem to fit the bill for what France is
now I was thinking about this earlier
obviously you're closer to French
culture than I am but I if I had to pick
something that now is maybe like the
great French national epic it might be
something like Les Mis yeah that's what
I exactly what I thought when you were
when you were talking yeah because I was
sort of guessing in the Revolutionary in
the Revolutionary mode it's something
that seems to function yeah as something
like that and it's got the right kind of
scale but it's also like a deeply Humane
work in a lot of different ways yeah and
it's not as mythological like because
they are modern a modern nature
um and then of course when it comes to
the Celts like the the the
Scottish Irish Banks uh Welsh like when
it comes to Celtic people you have so
many national epics it would be hard to
even pick one they're sort of the people
that like legitimately just had all the
stuff like right there for them because
uh because basically Celtic history is
just an extremely long history of lost
causes and heroes like all the way from
you know ancient times and like the the
tane all the way up to like Bonnie
Prince Charlie and all that stuff which
has which which has a uh uh like his
whole story has this kind of Mythic
flavor to it despite the fact has
happened you know relatively recently
historically speaking so what all of
these things have in common right is
that um
they're um they're they're things that
for something to be really effective as
a national epic typically speaking
It's gotta belong to a Mythic past
so this is part of why it's very
difficult to speak of like what would be
the American national epic or I assume
the Canadian national epic though yeah
the pro the thing with about that is
that the French Canadians have access to
a national epic but they basically don't
want anything to do with it because it's
so Catholic you know like the story of
the early uh settlers who came and died
and were kidnapped by Natives and
tortured and yeah like there's it's a
it's a it's a really beautiful and
intense and and uh and some of the early
like Samuel de Champlain was a was an
astounding character it's just that he
was so Catholic and so Christian that
that people don't talk they just can't
hold it in them to to tell that story
well that's interesting yeah I I I'd be
really hard put to like uh to say like
what's the national epic for America but
but again I think probably America's
just too large like you have to think of
it in terms of regional epics and a lot
of a lot of our big Regional stories
obviously see a lot of the big Regional
stories of the American southwest also
deeply Catholic stories yeah um and of
course American culture as a whole is
extremely anti-catholic
um there's
um there is uh you know uh
the the thing you know like I can't you
can you can barely even talk about this
on the internet right now but
um or even in you know polite company
but something like gone with the win
right the film right is is is very very
close to like something like a regional
epic for the Deep South yeah which is
not quite the region I live in but it's
pretty close
um and uh obviously
that is you know
that that that story you know for good
or for ill it's got to be discarded now
you know and obviously there are
problems with it but also but also you
know a lot of people found it to be a
really beautiful and compelling story so
but you know so but but there is
something like the wild west the
Antebellum South yeah the wild west is
has it has definitely has has its
mythology that is a real mythology yeah
Wild West is yeah mythology that's
pretty powerful yeah so so there is
there is something like mythological
time and what I'll be really interested
to see is you know who knows what's
going to happen you know the next two
300 years but uh you know a few hundred
years on like what is what what's our
what's our mythical past gonna be um
it's great that you're hopeful that
America will last that long I'm an
extremely optimistic person I don't know
what to tell you uh sorry to be so so
he's got so many crazy things are
happening right now no I mean it's a
it's a wild wacky time like I have no
idea what's gonna happen but I mean I'm
I am a very optimistic person so that's
one thing so let me ask you a question
yeah so how do you see so let's say now
you know we're kind of thinking about
this and this ReDiscover your stories
rediscovery of Legends yeah do you think
that there are ways for us to because
there are in these National epics are
beautiful and Powerful but like you said
there are some ways in which for example
Wagner is is almost demonized because of
the way that the Nazis use Wagner right
right but the the mythical elements of
the story are powerful and could be very
useful today do you think there are ways
that we can recapture kind of re-thread
some of these elements together to to to
maybe ReDiscover this more fractal
relationship you know that that used to
be the ancient way of thinking I mean
yeah yes I think and I not only do I
think it can be done I think it's got to
be done yeah um because I mean
there there are a lot of like great like
there's a whole genre of of novel called
like the Southern Gothic novel right
that is that's really built around the
um
the the the romance and the trauma of
the Southern United States right
um uh and uh so but but basically it was
just built out of people like trying to
work through this stuff by telling
stories about it and I think that um I
mean Wagner's ring cycle for instance
has already been extremely successfully
retold in the Star Wars franchise yeah
um
um you know like the first three Star
Wars films
are Wagner right it's like operatic in
its scope it's got the same like use of
light and darkness everything else uh
the whole idea of of the sun replacing
the father right you the sun has to kill
the father in order to in order to
ascend right that that whole idea right
super wagnerian fiend so I think but I
but I think that I think that yes these
stories have to be retold and we can
retell them in a way where we're also
kind of honest about
you know
um there's got to be a way
and I know you've done videos about this
but I'll just say there's got to be a
way to both love your ancestors and also
be honest about their sins yeah there's
got to be a way to do that and and right
now it seems like we can only do one or
the other but that's that's actually a
function of idolatry it's an image of
idolatry because one of the things that
happens is that because we don't have
the fractal relationship because we
don't have this hierarchy that leads all
the way up to God we actually expect of
these lower runs to be perfect and if
they're not perfect we hate them because
they're not perfect and so there's a
sense in which if things were properly
laid out and we don't treat these
figures as Idols to worship them or to
cast them down either way that we we see
them as just manifestations uh that have
that are gray because they're not God
you know all these leaders all these
Heroes have dark sides obviously there's
no there's no way around it right yeah
and we could celebrate their heroism and
also recognize their sins like it you
know and and some ways you know I think
that the idea to to cover their sins to
some extent in the sense that you know
we we want to emphasize the positive
because we want them to be examples in
their good things towards us like you
know what's the point of of just
pointing out all the evils of the people
that came before you what you want are
examples but if you can't find examples
then how can you get better like how can
you even live up to the beautiful
aspects of what has been given to you
yeah
yeah I don't know I'm trying to solve
The World's problems right now but we we
need to do it first of all by telling
good stories like yeah yeah let's do it
but that's how that's how this starts so
so just a couple more things about the
national epic and then we'll we'll I'll
segue into into some telling good story
stuff hopefully yeah
um so
all of these things let's say you know
when we go back and we talk about you
know Beowulf or the kalebala or the the
ring cycle or something all of these
things have the capacity
to be nested into the Christian story
right um not just historically but still
now right you know like this you know
Elites don't want you to know this but
storytelling is free you can just tell
stories right
um but uh if you don't do this I mean
this is the problem right this is why
things got really murdery
in the last century right is is that if
you don't Nest them and you try to put
on you know I think idolatry is exactly
the right language for it if you talk
about more weight on them then they can
bear then they start to develop some
problems uh first of all just for one
thing just insufficiently universalizing
right so like what do you what do you do
if you're trying to tell a story about
uh German people living in this country
we made up called Germany well now what
do I do with all the people who aren't
German right
um turns out the answers to that
question were pretty ugly right
um
one step in uh but the other thing is
that there are there's still a step in
the
um in the downward fragmentation of
identity right these stories did not
were not enough to hold identity
together over the long run that's right
and that's a that's important because
it's like it's now we can see patently
that is true yeah it's like maybe when
those stories were cast and when these
nation National identities were cast you
could have prophesied it and people
could have believed you or not believed
you but now as we noticed everything
turned to Mush uh we realized that no
those stories these National identities
even here in Quebec it's because us it's
like a very short concentrated time you
know it's like we went from the 1940s
50s as the most Catholic place in the
world to the 1970s with this major
nationalist movement to basically the
2000s where all of that doesn't matter
anymore and we're all just Global mush
I mean pretty fast here in the U.S
especially like growing up
uh you know very like conservative
fundamentalist right we had the founding
fathers right we didn't have any Saints
but we had the founding fathers right
George Washington Benjamin Franklin
Thomas Jefferson all those dudes right
and there was a lot of work expanded in
trying to really build up a kind of a
Christian mythology around them even
though many of them
we're not Christians many of them you
know universalists atheist deist Etc but
um but there was a lot of work put into
trying to basically build up a mythology
around that as well if we could just get
back to these guys then America would be
what it's supposed to be right
um and
just as a story
it's not strong enough it's it doesn't
have the capacity to confer identity you
know like what do you do with people who
don't fit into
don't fit into the story or what I mean
you know like you know even in in your
own like whatever Declaration of
Independence like who are the not people
all men are created equal women slaves
yeah that's a different thing but Matt
yeah I mean and I'm not just here to
like rag on my country yeah yeah sorry
that I live in but but but my point is
my point is that that story is itself is
actually great right uh those those men
actually lived you know yeah flawed
human beings or whatever but actually
lived interesting lives and did
courageous things and it's not wrong to
love them or praise them but if you try
to put on them the weight of the whole
American story
it's it's too much it's too much they
can't can't hold it right so
um the other thing is that very often
this kind of story
uh one of the deep flaws that it often
has is that very often this kind of
story is not participatory all right
there's there's really like uh now this
this differs I mean a lot of the if
you're really into American history
there's a lot of pretty cool
participatory things you can go to the
east coast you know uh and do you can go
to you know Washington's farm and like
they have like a bourbon night there
once a year and think like you know okay
I mean there's there's a really cool
place called Colonial Williams
Williamsburg where everybody's like
dressed up in Period costume and they
try to stay in character and you know
that's all fun so so like there are some
ways you can participate in the stuff
but but uh but ultimately it's not very
participatory right and then you then
like well okay but what if you're black
how do you participate in Colonial
Williamsburg right so it's like there's
like different there's just
is one of the one of the problems with
this kind of story is that for a story
to really confer identity it's got to be
something that you can actually
participate in you can make it a part of
your life so it's happening uh uh James
Taylor talks about this I mean for
orthodox Christians this will be a
really familiar concept but James Taylor
in a second age he talks about this idea
of you know chirotic time the idea that
that this moment that's maybe a mythical
moment or something that happened 2000
years ago becomes closer than yesterday
right that's what happens at posca is
that at posca the resurrection of Jesus
Christ a historical event a mythical
event all these layers to it but at on
the on posca night on Easter night it
becomes closer than yesterday yeah right
in terms of you know
um and so most of these stories don't
have a capacity to do that and when you
see people at least not completely yeah
not competitive capacity to do that yeah
you can celebrate the Fourth of July or
whatever they're thinking right right
yeah fair enough but like you said they
don't they don't they they just if they
tried to stand on their own as the
totalizing identity they they they end
up being dangerous actually yeah and
then of course I mean one of the
questions we've been dancing around for
a long time is and then what if you're a
brand new country right well what is
your Mythic time right and uh I think
we've kind of addressed that yeah so uh
let me let me uh let me give just like a
couple of like practical applications
for people it's the Baptist preacher in
me I can't totally get away from it uh
but also there's a couple of practical
applications but then also a little bit
about the project that I've been working
on and why it's tied into all of this so
if you wanted to
if you wanted to like comment all of
this stuff and you're trying to figure
out like what do I do with it what do I
do with this Universal history stuff
it's very it's very fun to like how do I
how do I actually participate in this
and integrate this into my life the
first thing that I'd say is for like for
you as a Christian
the liturgical year is your epic it's
your sacred story it's one that you can
totally participate in we have this
prayer
um in the evening or as part of our
evening prayers in the Orthodox Church
it comes from the service of complin
and it's addressed to the mother of God
and um I'm not going to unpack this or
defend this for our Protestant friends
out there
um please understand we mean something
by this that's maybe not well anyway
don't freak out I'll be happy to explain
this sometime later but we have in this
prayer we say you are the salvation
of the race of Christians now salvation
we mean like a lot more things by
salvation
um than you know like a they're dying
and going to heaven yeah then dying and
going to heaven so that's how we're
talking but uh she's the salvation of
the race of Christians in what way
because Christ comes from her
right and in that sense every single
Christian is descended from and is a
child of Mary yeah right but the thing
to kind of focus in on there is actually
that last bit the generation or the race
of Christians that when you pass through
the baptismal font you become something
more than just your you know this is why
Saint Paul you know this is why the
church can simultaneously we can talk
about there's no Jew Greek Bond free
male female but then also preserve
distinctions between those things in
important ways yeah we can do both
because of this
right and this is why I mean it's tied
back to my my long-running theory right
that you're not really a Christian
country until you have like
a definitive National icon of the mother
of God you know that's when you become
that's when you become a Christian
people right is because there's some
connection between her and the
Incarnation some connection between her
between the land between the yeah
between yes yeah all this body right
it's all these things that are there
yeah the the that which holds right it's
like that's what that's in some of the
motherland or however you want to think
about it all these all these ways of uh
describing it so then and I'll say this
especially to my like fellow Orthodox
converts right is that just sort of
understand and accept you've received a
faith which is
you know like cereal
Greco
Jewish in its Origins right like all the
early writers right all the all the
early hymns all these different things
they're not written by people from
America right so you're receiving this I
know it listen that's a dumb thing to
say but also it's like it's like weirdly
freeing to realize that so just like
realize that you're you're receiving
this Faith that's so much older than you
and that wasn't made with your tastes in
mind
and when people get like really like
let's say agitated
about
how you know well when are we going to
enculturate when are we going to have
like a single American jurisdiction when
are we going to have you know like
American culture really represented and
what about the music and yeah yeah yeah
you know all that stuff like like just
like settle down yeah settle down and
and accept the faith that you've been
given and but know that by doing so by
just like Faithfully saying your prayers
going to the services participating as
fully in the life of your parish as you
can that you're not just hopefully
participating in the salvation of your
own soul
but you're also participating in the
salvation of your ancestors
and of your culture
and I cannot stress enough how important
it is to fully accept and receive this
depositive tradition
if enculturation is ever going to happen
in a natural way yeah it's just like
we're talking about
committees can't do it it won't stick
It's gotta naturally arise It's gotta
just it's got to just arise out of so
that means of things that we won't be
able to describe afterwards so that in
500 years when the autospholis Orthodox
Church of Texas
um has officially replaced uh hummus
with guacamole as the Lenten dip of
choice
um you know like but but just like
nobody will remember how it happened
nobody remember but it's not like the
way we do things in 500 years we'll have
American Orthodoxy for good or for ill
it'll exist right and
um but but we're not going to get there
by like just trying to force things so
yeah anyway
um
uh so save your family
cultivate just kind of a normal holy
life
and um wait a few hundred years and see
what happens but yeah so all of that uh
with that graceful segue
um just real quick here I know the
videos kind of gone long but um just to
talk a little bit about the project
right so
um uh it's on Kickstarter right now
there will be a link down below where
you can click to it and go I would love
it if you would go and consider backing
even just like a couple of bucks to
watch the project or whatever
um if we get enough people backing then
it kind of like favors it the algorithm
and then Kickstarter will start
promoting itself and it'll have a much
larger reach yeah
um but just to say something about this
project why is this a thing that I'm
doing why is this really important or
significant what's it have to do with
the symbolic world and symbolism and all
this stuff
when I was growing up
I was part of a uh you know you know
came out of just extremely
uh fundamentalist conservative American
Christianity you know in the Deep South
all that stuff so growing up in that but
also growing up alongside a a Chinese
culture um because you know because we
came from a missionary family and they
adopted and so a lot of like Chinese
relatives and things like this and you
know like the actually the food that I
grew up mainly eating was like Chinese
food so like for me that's Nostalgia
that's oh that's mom's cooking right is
is Chinese
um and uh because she grew up over there
and you know um a lot of her siblings
she has you know Chinese siblings and
everything else so I kind of grew up
like in this one culture but also right
next door to this other culture
and uh yeah I mean to the point that you
know Mandarin was my second language as
a child and
um so I grew up right next door to this
other culture that that was was actually
really rich and old and had a sense of
its own
aesthetic right a sense of philosophy
sense of aesthetic sense of Storytelling
and you know certain way a certain mode
of expressing things and this is like
bright and colorful and then the thing
that is you know the lane that I'm in is
just like very beige I mean literally
beige I mean aggressively we chose to
like make our churches as a color like
why but anyway
um and so
trying to wrestle with that as a young
person is how this project was birthed
and it started out as trying to trying
to answer the question well what does it
take what does it what what do you need
to have a culture
and so when I was young I started
reading uh Beowulf and the song of
Roland first and then like a lot of the
other epics medieval epics and I became
totally in love with this idea of the
Epic and the national epic and all this
different stuff
um I hadn't you know I was pretty I was
like 10 or something at a time so I
hadn't really connected the dots on like
you know
you know where some of the stuff ended
up leading yeah if that's what you were
reading at 10 will forgive you Richard
yeah yeah yeah yeah
well anyway
so so I I just fell totally in love with
this stuff and and so and you know later
on as my as my literary Powers grew I
began to basically attempt to compose a
national epic like do what Tolkien did
but Tolkien did it mainly
uh linguistically at first
um and I am a linguist so there is a lot
of that in here but I was mainly focused
on the idea of like what's the what
would be the story that could be then
passed on like that people would get
their identity from and then As I Grew
Older I came to understand more and more
that it's not enough just to have a
story but that you actually need a
sacred story and you need like a sort of
a sacred participatory narrative and so
I kind of went from there to developing
you know to doing these kind of what-if
questions Tolkien and Lewis Lewis
especially famously used to talk about
this you know that when he was writing
you know the Narnia stories he really
just started out with like a what if
well what if I change this one thing
right and so for for me my what-if
question was like what would assaulter
be like in a fantasy world like how
would you like if if
um you know if God is still the god of
the fantasy world but but the Christian
religion the Incarnation hasn't happened
the Christian religion doesn't exist but
like you know like what would that look
like how would that play out and so
um and so like how do you how do you
make a uh like a fantasy religion that
is
still true it's not idolatrous that's
not demonic et cetera but also you're
not just like doing fantasy Christianity
which is which is in my opinion is
actually is actually worse it's actually
worse
um so
um anyway so I started developing and
kind of tinkering with these things and
then you know the histories and the
poetry and everything else kind of
developed
um into this much larger Mythic cycle
and
in a you know in a nutshell
um all the stuff that I've shared with
you today and all the stuff that we've
shared over the last two years of our
symbolic World Universal history
conversations is stuff that I originally
worked out by doing this you know I'd go
read like an Irish story or I'd go read
the kaliwala and then I would try to try
to figure out what that story was about
by writing a story like that so so like
working out my ideas but trying to work
them out in this creative way
um because for me the creative always
has to come before the analytical
um and so as for as for you know why
it's a tabletop role-playing game like I
said I'm gonna do another video soon
with Father dick and Nicholas kotar
where we talk about that particular
medium but basically the short version
is I think it's a powerful and very
overlooked storytelling medium there are
a lot of
um
um it's almost the only thing left it's
almost the only means left that has that
of telling a story that's not totally
controlled by by Hollywood and by you
know the big five publishing companies
and whatever big three or whatever it is
now but but just like there's there's a
Stranglehold on storytelling and like to
to to ever get back to where we could
even make a good Christian film yeah
we've got to First learn how to go all
the way back and just like tell stories
around the around the campfire yeah I
think that's a great way to phrase it
it's almost like a kind of laboratory of
Storytelling it's like yeah it's been
around and learning what stories are
made of and then people recognizing as
they watch people make decisions in the
story yes like watching what the results
of that are because they have real real
kind of consequences I think I think if
you phrase it that way I mean I don't
see how anybody could object because we
don't know how to tell stories anymore
and and so and this is the great thing
is that as a storytelling medium it's
participatory yeah right which is the
whole reason it's a role-playing game is
because I've been working on this stuff
for years and one day a good friend of
mine was like hey would you just run a
game for us setting because I've been
doing a Tolkien game for a long time uh
would you just run a game for a set in
this world that you've been working on
because I would like to know more about
it but you know it's kind of poetry is
pretty inaccessible to a lot of people
Etc and so we just started doing that
and then it kind of spun out from there
um but but what I would so what I would
encourage people is if this sounds cool
to you and you're not freaked out by it
maybe go back to project check it out
um but but also also to to encourage
everyone
that
we need to be telling these stories like
it's it's weird like lately I know a lot
of people like you but also other
friends who are who are trying to get
films off the ground and things like
this where we've been talking for years
and years about okay as Orthodox
Christians as traditional Christians Etc
we need to get out there we need to
start telling stories and making movies
and things like this and we're the
people with the most beautiful tradition
so let's share that with the world Etc
and then as soon as like people start
trying to work on these projects and get
people to fund them like everybody just
kind of dries up and they're like oh I
don't know about this fiction thing and
I'm not sure about this what about this
little detail and you know and like
people suddenly get really cold feet
they get really really nervous
um and I want to I would encourage
people to boldness and of course yes
we're gonna make missteps I'm gonna make
some you're gonna make some but uh well
we have to do this because
um you know this because at the end of
the day this this deep fragmentation of
identity has come down to now where we
have multiple identities warring within
ourselves or who we're supposed to begin
what we're supposed to be and what our
body should look like and everything
else and
if we don't have some you know if we
can't return to a narrative framework
that at least offers you know we don't
have an emperor we can't force this on
people but if we don't return people to
a narrative framework that at least
offers to heal them and reintegrate them
into this kind of nested
hierarchy this nested framework that
ultimately comes down to Holy Week like
if we can't if we can't offer some
people
uh uh an alternative in that way that
we're we're letting them now we're
failing them and we're not really we
won't we won't effectively communicate
the gospel right the reason Christianity
spreads the reason it takes off when it
goes places is because
you know uh obviously with some fits and
starts and mistakes and everything but
it always finds a way to contain the
culture right where you can where you
can then be a Russian or you know again
Russia also made up country but yeah you
can be a uh you can be a muscovite or
you can be a A kiavite or you can be
from nav garage or you can be from
Vilnius or you can be from London or you
can be from Paris and also a Christian
yeah and those things nest in on each
other so yeah you know that's actually
secretly that's what the whole project
is about so I hope people will check it
out cool so remind people tell them the
name and until when they've got to do
this because yeah it's called amborea
role playing in the world under
Starlight it's launching on Kickstarter
hopefully the same day that this
recording drops out on YouTube and I
think that it's going to run for a month
so I would encourage people to get out
and back it all right everybody you
heard Richard and so Richard thanks
again and uh we'll be paying attention
to to to the kickstarter and we'll talk
again very soon thanks thanks Jonathan